almost forgot I did get you them two
some hits too oh snap that's an even
better gift that's not all look behind
you but don't be obvious could I get uh
the me soft shell crab just grow them
he's eating his own Sushi that's the
most baller thing I've ever seen
guys my family just threw a garden party
to celebrate my brother's promotion it
was a huge success check it out there's
a video online heartwarming impromptu
father-son duet oh yeah oh yeah Oscar
you showed me this I've seen this that's
not you yeah whoa who's the sausage it's
my dad and my brother I would have
joined in but this melody doesn't really
support another Harmony Part so check it
out that's my brother's Boss look how
psyched he is he's having an awesome
time ah and did Robert California get an
invite to your party yeah of course yeah
I mean yeah I think he did Walter Baines
Bernard senior please report to the
stage uh I'm eating Andy come on
[Music]
okay okay
yeah what do you want to do well uh how
about one of our classic my other son
Duets
oh well sure
[Music]
[Applause]
right it feels strange
[Music]
yeah
okay
uh something like
saying I love you it's not the words you
don't come in yet I want to hear from
you
it's not that I want you
not to say but if you only knew more
than words is all you have to do to make
it real is anyone filming this seriously
Aaron it's either taping or calling
what would you do if my heart was
turning into you you know what Walter Jr
is here
why don't you come up and join us yeah
oh come up and do something with me I'm
just having a good time getting to know
Andy's friends here get up there and
sing or I will cut your larynx and
you'll never be able to sing again whoa
this old thing man I don't even
may the good Lord be with you down every
Road
and may sunshine and happiness around
you when you're far from home
and may you grow to be proud dignified
and true
unto others
[Music]
all right what's going on Cheers Cheers
Cheers get your own guitar
do you even know what you're doing yeah
yeah I know how to Hoist the Mainsail I
know how to
these buttons control bilge pumps and
stuff
I also know where the booze stash is
hello
oh God thank goodness you're here I was
having a little trouble uh with this
door yesterday I
think it was yesterday
I thought you were in rehab yeah I just
uh I figured I'd get that first relapse
uh out of the way
what's happened to our family everything
is so messed up
how did you even know I was in here I
didn't I just came to say goodbye to the
boat but
I've decided to sail it to Bermuda but
Bahamas Andy same thing
I need a crew you should be my crew
three weeks open ocean no booze you need
this I need it we need this serious bro
Time come on all right Guys cast us off
whoa All Aboard Aaron this is because of
you
realize that you're the best ever oh you
know just being a good girlfriend good
come on above and beyond the world's
greatest you did this
damn it I'm happy I'll see you in three
weeks okay hey bro it was here all along
no way way
Aaron I gotta go
there's McCords
foreign
all right